imagine that your uh 20 years old  and hey gen Z I want you to Imagine This  and your government calls you to war  they say we have no choice we are at war  with a great enemy and you must go fight  so you resist  and then one day when you're sneaking  out of your friend's basement because  you don't want to fight  a couple of uh cops see you chase you  down grab you and you get shipped off to  the front line you're at the front line  in Ukraine put the helmet on put on the  gear you have no time for training This  Is War  so you're pushed out into a middle of  the field and you're hiding in a hole  crying saying why am I here when a  grenade lands on you and blows up  that's what's happening to these people  many of these people fighting for Russia  are conscripts I'm not saying what  Russia is doing is good obviously I'm  saying it's bad  but to watch videos of these people and  then we're supposed to cheer on this  psychotic propaganda